hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to enter the gungeon just
judging by the music and the music is
freaking awesome here this game is gonna
be incredible it's actually a top seller
even though it's a new release on Steam
the marine I know I'm character
selecting okay the convict who looks
like a very angry lady cocky pilot
marine the hunter with a dog oh so I got
a choice here
that guy has kind of like the faux hawk
that I had before in kind of red hair
but she has a dog oh I'd love to go
around with chica because I got chica in
the room right now she's laying down
over there she's very tired she'd been
playing all day so I'm gonna go with
that one
alright who are you and her co-op I
don't have any friends I got no one to
play with
I'm literally by myself forever and ever
and ever where does Cisco high okay I
guess I won't go in there how about I
stay I'll go [ __ ] myself it's great okay
so I see I should have just gone north
this would have been the obvious choice
but then again I'm incredibly stupid hi
but what do we have here you must be a
new arrival
let me guess here to change the past
right well you're not the first but
there's no salvation here I was like you
once came to change the past
and now I have no future well maybe it's
cuz you drank it all the way alright
here we go
now the only thing I know about this
game is that it has to do with guns and
it's kind of a bullet hell the halls of
knowledge okay hello hi anybody here to
kill me anybody here for me to kill
hello wayward soul approached me in
press a to speak for it is i sir manual
heed my words and I shall show you how
to survive this occur third labyrinth
continue through the door to begin the
tutelage okay on my way teacher alright
try flipping these tables are kickin
barrels with the eben yeah [ __ ] that
table [ __ ] that barrel [ __ ] whoa
y'all
excellent interacting proceed to the
next room wait I'm not done [ __ ] all
the barrels okay I'm done
I'm moving on he's such a good teacher
what is this this is bad this is the
most important lesson you can dodge rule
by pressing L bumper and a direction
invulnerable for the first half of the
dodge okay ah okay gotcha okay I can do
it I'm on it and it to win it do it ah
boink boink boink that's awesome boink
Oh what this is not good enough oh thank
you
the door was very angry with me I love
this game already yeah so cool haha I
mean I know it's very simplistic and
obviously this is just a game but
whatever it's cool oh okay never mind I
already did it
I did the challenge because I'm really
good at games how [ __ ] is barrel okay
boy dying number of bullets can be
overwhelming oh hello for instant no
dodging through that but there's a way
to clear a path lengths using one will
delete all enemy projectiles in a room
and stop enemies from shooting for a
short period they will also push nearby
enemies away great if you need a second
to reposition pick them up by over oh
okay that's handy dandy okay
okay got it boink alrighty then good for
me [ __ ] all y'all okay excellent thanks
refill every floor so use them when you
need to they can also be found
throughout the dungeon but I wouldn't
rely on that onward okay thanks boss
you'll excuse me huh alright lucky oh I
guess I okay Who am I supposed to talk
to you you got the basics I suppose
you've earned a reward a gun befitting
your stature and experience cool sweet
it's a peashooter quite literally oh it
is a peashooter okay alrighty then
reload first you need something to shoot
one of the dungeons natural inhabitants
cruel savage and bloodthirsty oh gods
it's a bullet okay now that's why it's
called the gungeon kill him that's a
little wait
oh right bumper shoots oh that's gonna
be oh that's gonna be hard cold Bluffton
truly reutlitz you bar man you made me
this way teacher I didn't want to be I
came in here be riding to be peaceful
the next rooms will be real gun fights
kill all the enemies in each room and
the doors will open I'll meet you in a
few rooms ahead ok bye teacher yeah how
do I reload oh like that yeah I'm
killing bullets ah bucks ha sorry I'm
having a little too much fun on this one
OOP you're on acid me bro you shouldn't
whoa hello
I'm too good for y'all I don't know I'm
saying y'all I'm not even from Kentucky
from Cincinnati whoa hello that guy
means business okay well he doesn't mean
business no more over here hello
I mean it you know what a dodge roll
shooting used blanks but there's more to
learn you need to know how to use items
that don't exist in gun form this med
kit for example it will replenish your
health pick it up by a Persian problem
ah ok you got plenty how so don't use it
right trigger button to use it man why
the right trigger okay now yeah that's
much so that's much better
that's much better go on ok boss ha ha
ha ha hello what is that you see that
thing that's a teleporter thanks for
answering my question buddy to use it
open the map by left trigger ok alright
it's actually left bumper now ok how do
I get over to it I wasn't paying
attention to anything that you were
saying you are old man and no oops oh
[ __ ] I do okay why oh that's right okay
I shouldn't skip over there literally uh
okay got it
okay I can teleport to the blip
teleporter inuktun I'm okay they won't
work if I'm in combat press 800 standing
on the portal to tell that bird where
you were should explore better find the
boss okay I'll find the boss okay those
are nothing I thought those are gonna be
something hello hello
hello okay sorry didn't mean to do that
hi okay goodbye anybody here wanna fight
huh
wanna fight with me bro whoa hey I just
blew himself up why did he do that ah no
no no no this is a really cool bullet
hell I got to admit because it's kind of
stylistic in a great way which I always
like out of games but also this one is
just bonkers in terms of this like the
atmosphere of it like the music and like
it all works in cool I got high okay so
tables are defensive structures which
are very candy oh no poor guys I got a
blank good for me
no boss here so I just need to scout out
the rest of the dungeon until I find a
boss and then I need to kick him in the
ass until he gets an idea that I'm the
boss now pip not very clever when I said
I was at the boss oh as metal as [ __ ]
bro hello what are you the boss you're
the boss you ready to put all you've it
yeah let's do it then face me and sing
okay fine then I don't care I just met
you let's begin
alright fine sir manual OOP there you go
oh you're gonna lose it now what nope
nope nope nope why did you give me a
peashooter it's almost as if he really
wanted me to lose this because obviously
he's a little bit better at this than me
considering how many guns how many
bullets you can shoot at me sir I'm
trying to think think and move at the
same time quite difficult look I
actually might switch to the keep Hey
cease fire we never hello
boink can i no okay you've bested me I
the great manual so long if I ruled
these halls only to be undone by the
likes of you the reign of some annual
master of the gungeon ensign
ceremoniously eww beat the entire game
leave me here to die again okay alright
move I did it I'm the best
oh hello well that was weird things seem
to be quite bullet themed and I love it
oh man
the Sokol oh it just said generating
must be randomly generated for the most
of it hello did my Poochie help me at
all better co-op no I don't even know
what that is
tonight can I try mouse and keyboard
because I have a funny feeling that's
gonna be a little bit easier hello
Oh have you seen that misguided spirit
sir Manuel he's stuck in those halls
lost sad really
okay good for him at least he taught me
what I was supposed to be doing other
than you teaching me that alcoholism is
bad pip hello oh hi again wait
oh it's you forget how to dodge roll no
I'm good
take the stairs back up to the breach no
what well well they didn't let me
through did they let me through I may I
might have just had a seizure and
thought that they blocked me off from
the entrance which would have been much
much much much much much more
interesting hello excuse me can I please
you're now ready to enter the gungeon oh
well thank you I didn't know that I
didn't know that I needed to talk my way
through things I've only been taught to
kill literally I'm completely
bloodthirsty against anything that looks
like a bullet so I'm going to destroy
everyone that I come across except my
little boochi boochi
oh that don't sound good well that might
have been a horrifying mistake hello
desperado here so how do i seei whoops I
didn't mean to do that
woah okay hang on alright screw it I'm
I'm going back to the I'm going back to
this because I don't know how to whoa
he's spelling out letters hahaha that's
really cool that's it that's a clever
unique whoo hello no no no no no no what
are you doing at least I have an actual
gun now whoa whoa whoa Poochie are you
helping all [ __ ] helps oh thank you
Buchi
what did Buchi do what is this what is
that is anything that I can use yeah
nope apparently not
I don't know what that do No
Wow holy crap what the hell that guy is
big hey buddy
whoa no thank you I'd rather not
these guys aren't [ __ ] around anymore
oh god damn it oh it was a heart okay
that makes a lot more sense no thank you
okay so that was health that I could
have used if I had lost any health prior
to this
at least it's not one hit kills which is
usually how it is in these bullet hell's
at least there's a little bit of hope
for me going forward hello no not that
way hello anybody anybody want to fight
nobody hey hey hey hey okay we're kin oh
you where'd you come from
oh okay oh now they're open they weren't
open before are I fine hello whoa
hi there don't do that I actually don't
know if it's gonna be easier Wow
I'm sorry I didn't mean to do that all
right
I guess that's all in here there must be
something on the other side then OOP OOP
yep yep yep this is obviously not faster
than anything but it looks adorable when
I do it come on Poochie
what are you should I kill you just come
up to hell my god it was just a horrible
bird did it kill the bird
why did it hate you oh it's bullet oh
god it's bullet pooping Birds okay I
don't feel it bad I was gonna feel bad
but now I feel totally fine whoa hello
God Adam okay
it's like Dark Souls except absolutely
not like Dark Souls in any way in fact
that I feel bad for making that
comparison it's not it's not even
remotely like Dark Souls in any way it's
literally nothing to do with anything I
was saying anyway I'm gonna shut up now
about the stupid thing that's not okay
got that hello love that they come in
with a bang oh yeah sorry
god damn it you goofy bastard get away
from me bushi Tinkham chica get him
yeah I'm just gonna go I'm hoping that
there's gonna be another boss here
because I imagine that's what I'm aiming
for you cuz woo I mean I I know that
this is probably randomly generated and
and there's there's a lot to be done in
terms of replayability kind of like a
binding of issac style randomly
generated dungeons where you find bonus
items and [ __ ] like that and then
eventually get upgrades for your gun and
whatnot
but I imagine I imagine that if that is
the case that ooh hello what are you
what is you what is going on is there
something down here what does it say
what is that what's going on there's
something over there I don't know maybe
it's just not unlock yet hello have you
guys seen a boss around here anywhere no
okay trick joh they seem to know where I
am throughout the entire game so there's
no point hiding from anybody hey have
you have left
hello anybody want to die hello oh god
oh jeez I didn't look friendly at all
how I need to stop being so douchey
about this cuz I'm just I'm just going
in guns blazing excuse the pun but I'm
going in guns blazing oh oh so the
bullets are money oh that makes more
sense okay so that's what that was it
was a secret passage but it just wasn't
activated yet and that guy is the
shopkeep okay good I'll be more mindful
about collecting things but I just been
kind of enjoying the moment of
everything else hello buddy
nope no no no no
whoa that is terrifying you are big and
slow but I don't like you thank you
hello nope god it's so sad when they die
I never thought of bullets of having any
sort of emotion or anything to the fact
that they're like this entire dungeon is
populated by the oh hello is populated
by these things kind of weird bring of
mimicked friendship unlikely allies I
don't know what that means but I like it
does that mean they're gonna turn on my
side every once in a while because I'm
kind of lonely down in this Gunjan just
fending for myself no matter what
happens this guy be with the bosses oh
yeah it was okay bring it on
that's so cool I'll bring it on anyway
who all it's gonna be heavy from Team
Fortress 2 oh it's a bird oh I should
have known that's a bird nest that makes
a lot more sense now okay I got it oh my
god that's so cool oh god that's so cool
haha okay anyway oh man Gatling goal
that is that is almost embarrassingly
bad whoa hello okay you have fun with
that oh that doesn't seem good okay
there's nothing nothing new here oh wait
whoa whoa you're lucky I love bullet
holes and I'm good at them kind of not
really wookie what yep oh I can just
hold why was I I was pressing it
individually why did I need to whoa
whoa goddamn it got caught up on the
table up least I'll get some cover from
this [ __ ] oh no this is the one part
where I get to wail on you over and over
oh I got to repress it to reload that's
what I gotta do okay okay go almost
gotcha
what oh I brought shouldn't try to get
so close a who what are you doing there
what do you think you're doing Oh miss
me miss me
whoa didn't miss me there whoop ha jeez
oh jeez oh yes Oh gasp no oh my god I've
only got one health left
come on we don't [ __ ] this up now yeah
forgot yeah I cared I killed the rare
and mysterious bird known as Gatling oh
no on Oh
hegemony credit accepted galaxy all God
oh oh why did you do that oh hey cool
prototype railgun sweet oh so cool oh so
cool that's so cool
oh my god that is the coolest that is
the coolest that is the coolest oh my
god that's so cool okay so anyway that's
all the time I got for this episode
welcome to enter the gungeon this is
ridiculously cool and I can't wait to
play more of this in the future so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you think of this game down
in the comments below and try for
yourself it's on Steam I forget how much
it is but it's late I'll put a link in
the description thanks again and as
always I'll see you in the next video oh
goodness oh goodness look at me and then
some backup wheels over here just in
case